Christian Lindner ist der zuständige
Bundesfinanzminister Helena guten Abend
hallo einen schönen guten Abend sie
sagen der Haushaltsentwurf ist eine
Rückkehr zur Normalität heißt denn das
zur Normalität gehören jetzt immer auch
heftige Auseinandersetzungen innerhalb
der Regierung ums Geld
ich fürchte dass wir vor einer für unser
Land insgesamt schwierigen Zeit stehen
wir haben große
Bedarfe zu investieren etwa in die
Digitalisierung in den Klimaschutz wir
müssen mehr tun für den Bereich von
Bildung Innovation in unsere
Wirtschaftskraft zugleich haben wir hohe
Zinsen das bedeutet die Mittel sind
knapp und dann muss sehr genau
miteinander gesprochen werden wo die
knappen Mittel eingesetzt werden sehr
genau miteinander gesprochen jetzt gab
es ja in der Vergangenheit eine ganze
Menge Streit hat sich auch alles sehr
sehr lange hingezogen vielleicht gucken
wir mal kurz auf ein zwei Details die
Kinder Grundsicherung ist ja gerade
aktuell in der Diskussion die bekommt
jetzt einen Bruchteil dessen was die
Ministerin dafür will um Kinderarmut
einzudämmen eigentlich war das mal ein
gemeinsames Projekt der Ampel das
Elterngeld wird für Gutverdiener
gestrichen überall sieht die
Familienministerin Sie Herr Lindner als
den Schuldigen können sie damit gut
leben
nein wir haben ja die Mittel auch für
den Bereich von Familien und von Bildung
verstärkt man kann die Geschichte auch
anders erzählen wir schaffen ein
startchancenprogramm 4000 Schulen sollen
unterstützt werden gerade dort wo es
besondere soziale Aufgaben gibt etwa mit
einer besseren Ausstattung beim
Elterngeld ist das letzte Wort noch
nicht gesprochen die Familienministerin
selbst hat ja bedenken bei der von ihr
jetzt konkretisierten Maßnahmen selbst
sagte diese Maßnahme ist ihr vom
Finanzministerium ans Herz gelegt worden
und zwar sehr deutlich anders etwas
anders also das ein fdp-vorsitzender
Menschen mit hoher Qualifikation
Leistungsträger belastet ich glaube das
ist eher unwahrscheinlich dass das mein
Wunsch ist aber eins ist richtig wir
müssen die Ausgabensteigerung auch beim
Elterngeld gegen den Bundeshaushalt
begrenzen das ist ja die mit größte
Leistung im Haushalt des
Familienministeriums aber wie das im
Einzelnen passiert das ist in der
fachpolitischen Verantwortung
erklärt sie sagen sie wollen die
Leistung beim Elterngeld begrenzen aber
wollen irgendwie dann doch nicht als
fdp-vorsitzender wie sie gerade sagten
ans Elterngeld dran wie sollen das jetzt
beides zusammenpassen es gibt ja andere
Möglichkeiten was man tun kann es muss
ja nicht eine einkommenskappung bei
150.000 Euro sein sondern es sind ja
auch andere Möglichkeiten was man dort
tun kann
übrigens übrigens könnte man auch an
anderen Stellen im Einzelplan des
Familienministeriums bei anderen
Programmen Mittel organisieren das hat
ja etwa das Wirtschaftsministerium
gemacht ich habe eine Ausgaben
Obergrenze für das
Wirtschaftsministerium vorgeben müssen
Ausgestaltung aber da hat natürlich
immer Vorrang das was die zuständigen
fachministerinnen und Fachminister sagen
einer Tatsache Siebert kommen wir nicht
vorbei wir reden doch Siri ich verstehe
dass sie über Einzelmaßnahmen sprechen
nur mir ist der strategische Blick
entscheidend wir müssen die
Schuldenbremse einhalten wir haben hohe
Inflation und wir haben gleichzeitig
gefahren was die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung angeht wir können also die
Steuern nicht erhöhen gleichzeitig
müssen wir rekordmäßig investieren damit
dieses Land weiter Zukunft hat und das
bedeutet es müssen auch unpopuläre
Entscheidungen getroffen werden und was
sie jetzt aber gemacht haben Herr linda
ist ja ganz interessant sie haben die
großen Batzen also wirklich das ganz
große Geld haben sie ihn neben Haushalte
ausgelagert das sind gigantische
schuldentöpfe muss man sagen nehmen wir
zum Beispiel den Klima und
Transformation vor der die Energiewende
abfedern anstoßen soll der ist erstmal
ausgeklammert worden dabei umfasst der
an er allein dieser Form allein fast 40%
des gesamten regulären Haushalts ist der
klassische Haushalt dann nicht auch
irgendwie eine Mogelpackung geworden
nein im Gegenteil wir werden 2024 5
Sondervermögen abschaffen die wird es
nicht mehr geben das heißt mein Ziel ist
die zu reduzieren ja aber die großen
Sondervermögen also sonderschulden
sprich für die Bundeswehr und für Klima
und Transformation die sind ja weiter da
und die sind so gigantisch dass sie vom
vom Volumen her schon fast an die Hälfte
des gesamten Haushalts rankommen das ist
doch ein umbuchen und ein ich sage jetzt
mal vorsichtig gesagt ein kreatives
umbuchen was sie da veranstalten nein
ich buche ja äh kann ich so kreativ und
wie sie sagen wir haben erstens das
Sonderprogramm für die Bundeswehr im
Grundgesetz das ist eine im Grundgesetz
verankerte einmalige Ausnahme für die
Ertüchtigung der Bundeswehr weil wir die
Vernachlässigung sonst so schnell gar
nicht dort beseitigen könnten zum
zweiten haben wir den Klima und
transformationsform der hat eigene
Einnahmen beispielsweise aus dem
CO2-Preis und er hat eine Rücklage
dieses Sondervermögen wurde von der
Vorgängerregierung übrigens eingerichtet
aber der ist klar Herr Lindner wie er
genau aussieht wie hoch ist der denn zum
Beispiel dieser Fonds haben sie da schon
konkrete Angaben machen können heute ja
natürlich es sind etwa 170 Milliarden
Euro geplant für die ganzen nächsten
Jahre und wie im letzten Jahr und in der
Vergangenheit kommt der Wirtschaftsplan
nach dem Haushaltsentwurf auch das ist
jetzt nichts Neues und es gibt etwas
Drittes Herr Siebert es gibt den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds der
wurde von der Vorgängerregierung während
der corona-pandemie eingerichtet und in
diesem Fond sind viele Kredit
Ermächtigungen die wir aber zum Glück
nicht nutzen die waren nämlich
exklusiv für die Strom und
gaspreisbremse und zum Glück haben die
Preise sich wieder reduziert so dass die
Mittel die dort zur Verfügung stehen es
waren mal 200 Milliarden Euro an
Ermächtigungen die werden sehr weit
überwiegend gar nicht ausgeschöpft und
der Zweck wird auch nicht verändert
lassen Sie uns noch ganz kurz über ein
anderes aktuelles Thema reden
Finanzminister hat ja mit allem zu tun
wie sehr tut es ihnen weh dass der Bund
jetzt 243 Millionen Euro Schadensersatz
zahlen muss wegen der verkaufsten
Pkw-Maut holen Sie sich das vom
ehemaligen Verkehrsminister Andreas
Feuer zurück
das sind Entscheidungen der
Vergangenheit gewesen die sich jetzt als
falsch herausgestellt haben auch gegen
guten Rat seinerzeit und das müssen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger jetzt politisch
bewerten was ein Verkehrsminister der
CSU der csu-vorhaben umsetzt was der am
Ende für den Steuerzahler gebracht hat
politisch bewerten und auch bezahlen
die Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler
müssen das bezahlen und zugleich können
Sie das aber dann auch politisch
bewerten sagt der Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner vielen Dank für das
Gespräch ja gerne